ich habe keine Idee was ich heute essen
soll aber zum Glück habe ich einige gute
Kollegen und Freunde die mir vielleicht
den ein oder anderen Tipp geben können
wir werden einen Tag lang Youtuber
entscheiden lassen was ich esse ich bin
sehr gespannt ob ich gute Empfehlung
bekommen auf die Empfehlung eher
schlecht sind vielleicht Neiße Rezepte
coole Inspiration reden wir nicht lange
rum und rufen die erste Person direkt an
es wird Zeit für unsere erste Mahlzeit
und ich habe eine Idee wenn wir anrufen
können Papa Platte hat bestimmt was
Gutes im Sinn weil er ist ja ein
begnadeter Koch mit mir gemeinsam hat er
auch schon gekocht und schauen wir mal
was uns empfiehlt Bro ich bräuchte deine
hilfe ich brauche eine Empfehlung was
kann ich mir jetzt direkt auf entspannt
morgens zum Frühstück gönnen egal was du
willst ich werde es essen okay
das machen aber so mit so einem mit so
einem geilen vielleicht sogar dazu oder
sowas
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen geile
sortiert dazu und ein geiler Typ okay
ich glaube darauf können wir auch bauen
okay geil ich küsse auf dein Herz
das würde ich sagen ist eine Ansage
breakfast Kesha dir mit Rührei drin das
wird ein bisschen schwer das nicht zu
übergaren weil der Käse muss ja
schmelzen und so Nachos drin geiler Dip
dazu Freunde es kommt komplett meine
Wave ich liebe gerade mexikanisches
Essen lass uns einkaufen und ein schönes
Frühstück zaubern wir haben eingekauft
und nicht irgendwie irgendwas wir haben
feinste Zutaten für Kevins Gericht wir
machen das ist richtig pervers eine für
trocknete Tomaten smoke-paper Mario Käse
einfach getrocknete Tomaten in Öl das
ist auch das Öl von den getrockneten
Tomaten dazu nehmen wir ein bisschen
geräuchtete Paprika wenn es ein bisschen
mehr als auch nicht schlimm dann gehen
wir noch ein Ei dazu ein bisschen Senf
dazu das ist eine Sache jedermann
nachmachen soll ein klein wenig Honig
noch dran
und fertig ist unser smoke caprika right
tomato
getrocknete Tomate geräucherte Paprika
Dip als nächstes hat Kevin gesagt dass
wir karamellisierte Zwiebeln brauchen
ich muss sagen ich bin echt gut
weggekommen bei Kevin weil der hätte mir
auch was übles geben können jetzt wie
gesagt haben wir diese perfekten
Streifen mein Topf ist hier den mache
ich heiß und gebe ordentlich Butter
hinein nehmen wir uns jetzt unsere
Zwiebeln und geben Sie in unseren Topf
das ist auf jeden Fall die Sachen die am
längsten braucht weil schnelle
karamellisierte Zwiebeln gibt's nicht
ein bisschen Zucker dazu und meine
geheimzutage steht hier kann man
ungeduldig ist kann man die braune Farbe
auch mit wash ist wirklich jeder sagen
dass sie es falsch schreibe Soße mit der
kann man es auch machen so und jetzt
einfach mal bevor jetzt jemand in den
Kommentaren wieder was schreibt ich
blende euch jetzt in dem Video ein wie
es richtig ausgesprochen wird
whistischer
Arbeiten kümmern wir uns schon mal um
das Rührei soft scramide voll praktisch
eigentlich für die Gäste in
handlungszeichen von diesem Formate die
können einfach was sagen was sie schon
immer machen wollen dann kriegen
fertiges Rezept von uns Butter
das Rühren beginnt das große rühren
weiter geht's mit der quesadilla dafür
gebe ich ein bisschen Öl auf unsere
planscher lege dann eine Tortilla nieder
darauf geriebener Mozzarella Deckel
drauf
schweren das ganze das heißt es noch ein
bisschen warten und wir können schon
flippen das ganze wenig Farbe haben sie
schon angenommen wir helfen jetzt ein
bisschen nach mit der westlicher Soße
einfach ordentlich was dran geben das
ist auch einfach ein Geschmacks Booster
und sie da sie sind perfekt
karamellisiert heben wir den Deckel ab
so stelle ich mir zumindest vor
auf leg kurz ab Rührei rein das ist aber
Crunch Rap Style ein letztes mal
gewendet und jetzt richten wir an auf so
einem schönen Brett sowas leckeres zu
Essen zu sehen Freunde wenige wirklich
wenige Produkte sind noch verfügbar
Block vom Shop schaut mal vorbei danke
auf jeden Fall für den Support das ist
wirklich crazy guck mal was wir
gezaubert haben
oder das ist der Typ das ist Mario aus
getrockneten Tomaten mit geräucherter
Paprika hier drin haben wir so die
krispy Tacos Rührei karamellisierte
Zwiebeln sei seid ihr gewiss wir haben
deine Vision ausgeführt ich probiere
jetzt weil ich glaube wirklich das
brutal
aber das ist pervers also du hast eine
sehr gute Vision
fragen wir mal den Marky hier was der
dir zum Mittagessen geben wird bin
gespannt ob es auch so lecker wird hallo
mein lieber Mark wie geht's ach bestens
du ich bräuchte ein wenig Inspiration
für eine Speise die ich mir zubereiten
oder essen gehen kann und du hast
vielleicht einen heißen Tipp für mich
vielleicht wortwörtlich weil wir wissen
ja dass du gerne scharf bist
ne
und zwar sind das tatsächlich Chicken
Wings
abends Chip du kennst diese Challenge ne
oh oh
okay dann ähm danke dass du mein Leben
hier mit beendet hast
ich danke dir Mark ich sag dir wie es
war falls ich dann auch lebe ciao ciao
der hatte sich das schon zurechtgelegt
ich wollte darauf so ein bisschen hinaus
dass er sagt ja mach dir doch mal ein
scharfes irgendwas Bro wir müssen diesen
Chip finden und ich habe das noch nie
gegessen ne also ich glaube das wird
richtig richtig weh tun aber für Mark
machen wir es doch gerne dreimal hot
Chips Chicken Wings und ich habe einfach
nur Angst Leute wirklich ich glaube das
wird verdammt hot bzw verdammt heiß und
ich würde bin ich ganz ehrlich
vielleicht lieber draußen sitzen auf
einer Liege nicht erfrischen mit einem
schönen Mojito aber ich muss ja noch
arbeiten deshalb vielleicht ein Virgin
Mojito sowie mein Partner er hat jetzt
herausgebracht hat aber neben Virgin
Mojito gibt es auch altbekannte
Klassiker wie Honigmelone oder Kokosnuss
also perfekt für den Sommer und das
beste ist bis zum 13.08 könnt ihr 10 %
auf alles sparen Klick dafür einfach auf
den Link unten in der Videobeschreibung
und gebe den Code ein ihr kennt ja
mittlerweile auch die stilworte die ich
so gerne benutze die passt nicht so
perfekt zum Sommer in der mattschwarzen
Optik deshalb hat er ab die neue
stilbeutel rausgebracht die Silver steel
bottle man unschwer erkennen kann wie
das ganze Konzept von Erb funktioniert
habe ich euch ja glaube ich schon zu
genüge erklärt ich trinke jeden Tag mit
der erbflasche und gerade in den heißen
Tagen hilft es mir sehr weil man trinkt
einfach nicht nur wenn man sich daran
erinnert sondern weiß Spaß macht mit der
großen Variation von Porz habe ich immer
den richtigen Geschmack und gesund ist
es auch noch denn effektiv trinke ich
Wasser und verzichte damit auf viele
zuckerhaltige oder andere Getränke das
gibt's noch viel Getränke also Freunde
über den Code Max und den Link in der
Videobeschreibung könnt ihr bis zum
13.08 10 % auf alles sparen ich wünsche
euch viel Spaß damit weiter geht's mit
den schärfsten Wings der Welt vermutlich
du ziehst ja schon fleißig die
Handschuhe an aber das ist auch nötig ne
ja also ich mache sie jetzt gerade wegen
des Hähnchens und danach weil ich halt
mit diesen Chips hantiere ich glaube das
wird wirklich übel und ich habe auch
noch kein echtes Verständnis dafür wie
krass das wird so teile ich jetzt das
Hähnchen einfach in Flaps und Drums
zumindest da haben wir alles was wir für
gute Chicken Wings brauchen ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob ich gewappnet bin
für das was jetzt kommt wir nehmen uns
Cursor das sieht glaube ich nicht
umsonst aus wie ein Sarg hier denn
dieser Chip hier hat es in sich dieser
Chip hier 2 Millionen Scoville können
wir auch vorstellen dass die Luft beim
Frittieren auch keinen Spaß sein wird
also können wir noch zwei weitere rein
Grüße gehen raus an Mark der nächste
Tipp und wir wollen natürlich nichts von
der schönen Schärfe verlieren deshalb
klopfe ich mir hier auch alles aus hier
ist unser Dach gucken dass wir das schön
einarbeiten das sieht schon aus wieso
der grüne die Chicken Wings sind
goldgelb frittiert Verständnis komplett
der Rest der Chips geht drauf
fertig sind die Todes
da sind die Dinger es sieht wirklich
nicht böse aus es riecht auch nicht so
schlecht aber hast du den schon gegessen
in one ship
ja ja klar so vom Filmabend so ne setzt
man sich mal hin und gönnen sich was
leckeres ne
auf dich
wow
essen aber
ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen
schade
[Musik]
jetzt zündet aber
okay aber für dich um dich stolz zu
machen mag ich danke dir für deine
Rezeptidee wir sehen uns ja
okay Freunde als nächstes rufen wir Tom
Supreme an und ich hoffe das ist ein
bisschen angenehmer wird ich brauche
Inspiration für mein heutiges Abendessen
was kann ich mir kochen soll ich essen
gehen einfach ein heißer Tipp von dir
was ich mir gönnen kann
ja okay also ich sag mal so wenn du das
jetzt sagst ne was soll ich denn da
jetzt anderes noch machen
kleine schöne Süßkartoffel
okay geil ich küsse doch dein Herz sehr
gut das mache ich genauso Kuss ich sage
dir wie es geschmeckt hat los geht's
heute machen wir uns ans Koch hier
drüben haben wir schon Süßkartoffel
Würfel die ein bisschen vor sich hin
kochen damit wir Sie zu einem schönen
Püree machen können und hier vorne
brauche oder Kamera das war nicht ganz
zu haben
hier vorne ist die planschaft für den
absoluten Star heute danke Tom dass ich
wegen dir vagio von meiner
steuerersetzen kann hier ist unser
wunderschönes ich sage euch ehrlich
Leute ich habe mir nur die Hälfte davon
genommen weil das möchte man mit Andacht
Essen und die andere Hälfte gönn ich mit
einem schönen Bierchen oder einen
schönen Glas Wein zu Hause auf
entspannen deshalb nur anteilig von der
Steuer Scheiße diese wunderschöne Fett
Cap auch ne die wieder an der Seite
haben ich gucke hier einmal nach unserer
Süßkartoffel die braucht ja
bekanntlicherweise immer ein bisschen
paar Minuten dann sind wir soweit hier
hinten raucht unsere planscher schon an
die schöne Arbeit lasse ich ein bisschen
von dem Radio Fett aus
legen die eine Seite nieder bewegen es
nicht weiter bis es einen wunderschönen
Kruste hat der heutige Tag ist eine
schöne Repräsentation für meinen Job
manchmal muss man Leiden und die schönen
Dinge erleben gucken wir mal
WoW und so lassen wir es einfach noch
mal kurz ruhen jetzt schöpfe ich unsere
Süßkartoffeln ab gibst du hier in Becher
und unser Mixer kriegt einen zweiten
Auftritt das verfeinern wir jetzt mit
Sahne muss ich fragen was fragen ob das
schmeckt was bedeutet
bitte
einmal kräftig durchführen und alles
servieren wow zeigen unser Finales
Produkt
naja dann schicke ich ein Foto davon
Feedback aber probiert zunächst einmal
das Püree verstrichen aller Maximilian
Lorenz
absolute Geschmacke wirklich butterweich
samtig Muskatnote ist da schöne
Salzigkeit und einfach sehr sehr cremig
durch die viele Sahne dazu die
Kaiserschoten nicht schöner knackt eben
die perfekte frische mit rein und eine
Sache muss ich glaube ich nicht weiter
erläutern unser Radio falls ihr euch
denkt dass es vielleicht zu rare oder
irgendwas ich finde das ist die beste
Art und Weise zu genießen das sagt auch
die Fleischproduktion hole eine Minute
pro Seite kurz ruhen lassen denn nur so
kann man halt die wirkliche Qualität von
dem Fleisch auch erleben
also das ist wirklich wirklich wirklich
wirklich krass ich glaube der Begriff
meld in your mouth wurde wirklich für
bague erfunden weil größte den Mund und
Schmelz weg und lässt dabei wirklich die
himmlischen umami-aromen frei du dir nur
vorstellen kannst interessante
Kombination die natürlich ein bisschen
auf den Geldbeutel geht macht euch das
sonst mit dem normalen schönen Steak
kann man sich auch mal gönnen auf dem
Sonntag oder so dann ist das wirklich
brutal ich würde sagen Leute das Video
hat mich sehr positiv überrascht wir
hatten Spaß wir hatten challenges wir
haben geile neue Rezepte kreiert
gemeinsam mit den Gästen die sie uns
vorgeschlagen haben falls ihr davon ein
paar zwei sehen wollt schreibt in die
Kommis danke an die Jungs die mitgemacht
haben und bis zum nächsten Mal ciao